et nous la musique rock in mexico
accueil espace
ça faisait un moment qu'on se disait il
pourrait peut-être faire un truc type
d'exercice l'iphone se disent c'est un
kiff de comédiens de jouer plein de
plein d'univers différents j'ai commencé
la production etc et il manquait en
effet quelques sketches et je viens d'y
entrer move your life 2 oui jagger
travers tombe sur un toit oui après il
n'y a pas de remords déjà ça fait peur
il fait froid tu fais un voire pas de
degré et aucun degré heureusement le
ciel est avec nous parce qu'il est uni
là c'est un temps moche mais c'est
parfait pour un tournage n'est pas le
soleil qui vient et qui s'en va et le 15
décembre
je suis revenu et c'est bien on fera
bien le même mouvement exactement un
truc en fait c'est que tes mouvements
ils sont hyper importants donc fait bien
exactement le même mouvement avec toutes
les cagoules tous mes trucs
ouais c'est bien ça c'est bien le truc
que j'avais un peu oublié mois sur nos
visages chlef c'est qu'en fait c'est
chiant à produire ans c'est trop vous
font se met dans la peau de pirate plein
d'univers différents les uns des mômes
et en même temps en production c'est
horrible parce que c'est à chaque fois
un univers un maquillage différent des
costumes différents un lieu différent
des visites entre 12h et 13h je sais pas
exactement
et on bouge dans un bois pour faire un
plan soit une falaise même presque pas
trop en retard la 7e journée improbable
le cri du mec a pas peur bah ça va
changer avec plus galérer avec le fonds
vert c'est un très grand mais quand j'en
sais faire croire un précipice je tends
mélasse moi qui tendent à chaud c'est
par ces mots là je vais faire diversion
du fait diversion ça très vite plein
d'univers et sur notre trop vite et tu
fais moi c'est hyper riches
il ya plein de choses devant tous ces
fabriques de déplacer beaucoup et obligé
d'étaler le tournage sur plusieurs jours
parce que tu dois faire plein de
déplacement donc c'est un peu la course
on lance un tout pour que rien qui vous
a des trous et c'est ce que j'ai fait un
premier tome
bertrand tombe et ensuite c'est vraiment
excellent deuxième top et sarah temps
donc c'est d'être en avant action on a
un guest only be qui est facilement
reconnaissable
oui c'est un mec drôle avec gros qui
fait les chroniques rigolote couvrez la
glace ça marche et qui travaille dans la
télé avec avec mon sosie
alors on s'en sort comme sur des
roulettes attention bien joué merci
guidon est ce que tu sais comment on
fait des pâtes c'est la référence un peu
pour ce sketch c'est un peu la séquence
de augmente d'un mariage entre orlando
bloom et la petite blonde que j'aime pas
trop tard car avec les exactement elle a
beaucoup trop de consonnes ans on est en
tout huit pyatt de chorégraphier une
mini les bastons bien se positionner
comme le profil au congo je fais
semblant on se parle et agit comme sur
des roulettes
et là je m'écarte toute attaque qui te
dire un truc on se sent comme sur des
roulettes
attention c'est intéressant que de faire
un break de foot en même de la gueule du
dd 2 et du conseil de ville expose le
concept est en plus loin avec crazy life
avec mexico and space par totalement
live je suis désolé mais le buzz du
corps je suis trop vieux pour ces
conneries ça devient autre cascadeur à
titre et à son véhicule et s'est enfin
mais en plus ce qui les rend trop vite
la cascade toile n'est vraiment pas
facile parce que et des repères de
bouffer c'est à dire le minivan en fait
qu'ils avaient loué pour nous
transporter quoi action
c'est james bond sont des gamins action
nickel alors on n'avait pas une vue sur
comment bien utiliser un mec ans mourir